ALICIA WILLIAMS: One of the
benefits of a data warehouse,
like BigQuery, is the
improved simplicity and speed
of bringing data to your
analysts and decision-makers.
Data needs vary
across a company based
on organizational
function, geography,
and more, so it's
important to be
able to provide customized
access to your users
without adding unnecessary risk.
In today's episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight,"
we're showing you how to
create authorized views, which
give you the ability to define
and share a specific subset
or view of your BigQuery data.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BigQuery organizes data into
containers called datasets.
These datasets function
like top-level folders
that organize and control
access to the underlying tables.
In our episode, "Managing
Access with Cloud IAM,"
we talked about how
to manage access
at the data set and
table level using
the Identity and Access
Management Service,
or Cloud IAM.
If you want to check it
out, we've linked it below.
Cloud IAM can restrict access
down to the table level.
But what if you want to
restrict access for members
to parts of a table?
In BigQuery, one way
to accomplish this task
is by creating authorized views.
An authorized view
allows you to share
the results of a query with
a specific user or group
without giving that user
access to the tables that
were queried.
For example, let's say
as a BigQuery data admin,
you wanted to give an analyst at
your company access to a table
containing your
service request data,
but you wanted to remove the
full address of the service
location.
You could write a query that
didn't include the address
column and then save the
results as an authorized view
to share with the analyst.
Creating an authorized view
follows a defined series
of steps.
Step one, start with
your source dataset.
This is the dataset
with the sensitive data
you don't want to share.
Step two, create a separate
dataset to store the view.
Authorized views
require the source data
sit in a separate
dataset from the view.
Don't worry about
the reason why.
You'll see in step six.
Step three, create a
view in the new dataset.
In the new dataset,
you create the view
you intend to share
with your data analysts.
This view is created
using a SQL query that
includes only the data
the analysts need to see.
Step four, assign access
controls to the project.
In order to query the
view, your analyst
needs permission to run queries.
Assigning your analyst
the BigQuery user role
gives them this ability.
This access does not
give them the ability
to view or query any
datasets within the project.
Step five, assign
access controls
to the dataset
containing the view.
In order for your analysts
to query the view,
they need to be
granted the BigQuery
data viewer role for that
specific dataset that
contains the view.
And finally, step six,
authorize the view
to access the source dataset.
This gives the view itself
access to the source data.
We need to do this
because the view takes
on the permissions of
the person using it,
and since the analyst doesn't
have access to the source
table, they'd
otherwise get an error
if they tried to
query this view.
We're going to jump into the
console and see how it's done.
You can follow along in your
own BigQuery sandbox, which
you can set up for free
following the instructions
in the video link below.
We're using two
sandboxes in order
to represent the
perspectives of both the data
admin and the analyst.
OK.
Starting out as the
data admin, step one,
you'll need a dataset to
store your full source
data containing the
sensitive address field.
From the BigQuery Console,
select your project
and click CREATE DATASET.
Give your dataset a name
and click the Create dataset
button.
Now you'll populate a table
within the dataset using a SQL
query.
Click COMPOSE NEW QUERY
and copy and paste
the Source Data Query that's
linked in the description
below into the Query Editor.
Before running the query,
go into Query Settings
and check the box for
Set a destination table
for query results.
Verify your project and
dataset name are selected,
then name your table
service_requests.
Click Save.
Now click Run.
When the query completes,
you can select your new table
in the left-hand nav
and click Preview to see
that the data was populated.
Step two, time to create a
separate dataset where you'll
put the view for your analyst.
You'll follow the same
steps we just performed.
Select your project and
click CREATE DATASET.
Name your dataset shared_views
and click Create dataset.
Step three, now you'll create
the view for your analysts.
Click COMPOSE NEW QUERY
and copy and paste
the View Query linked
in the description
below into the Query Editor.
This query selects all the
columns from the source data,
except for the
sensitive address field.
Now click save view.
Make sure your project
and dataset are selected
and give the view a name.
Click SAVE.
You can see that the view is now
populated in the left-hand nav.
We have our source table
and our analyst view set up.
Time to start assigning access
controls for our analyst.
Step four, give the
analyst permission
to query in the project by
assigning the BigQuery user
role.
From the navigation menu, head
to IAM & Admin and click IAM.
Click ADD.
In the members field, enter
the analyst's email address,
or as we are using,
a Google Group
that contains your analysts.
In the roles field,
click Select a role
and choose BigQuery User.
Click Save.
Head back to BigQuery by using
the search bar in the console.
Step five, next, you'll
give the analyst permission
to read the dataset
that contains the view.
Select the shared_views dataset
and then click SHARE DATASET.
Click Add members.
Again, enter the email or
group for your analysts.
Select the role
BigQuery Data Viewer,
then click Add, and
finally, click Done.
Step six, you need to
give the view itself
access to the source dataset.
This is what is meant
by an authorized view.
From the source dataset,
click SHARE DATASET.
And then this time, head to
the AUTHORIZED VIEWS section.
Change the dataset
to shared_views
and select your
view for the table.
Click Add and then click Done.
Your authorized view
configuration is now complete.
Let's flip over to
the analyst's account
to see the result from
their perspective.
The analyst is logged in and
has selected the same project,
analytics-source-data.
Let's verify what data
they are able to view.
As you can see, the analyst is
able to both access the view
and run queries
over it, but when
they try to view the source
table, they do not have access.
Now you're ready to
use this same process
to create any number of
authorized views customized
for your groups and
users at your company.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight,"
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]